[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin in allen guten Abend der
Blick nach Wimbledon und zur Tour de
France später bei dir Christine so ist
das guten Abend außerdem haben wir das
noch für Sie vorbereitet
viel Lob und ein wenig Selbstkritik auf
seiner sommerpressekonferenz verteidigt
der Kanzler die Arbeit der Regierung
kritisiert aber den öffentlichen
ampelstreit
zwei Jahre nach der Flut das Ahrtal und
NRW erinnern an die Opfer der
Wiederaufbau ist noch lange nicht
abgeschlossen
Hollywood steht still nach den
Drehbuchautoren streiken in den USA
jetzt auch die Schauspieler Filme und
Serien verzögern sich wohl
[Musik]
es ist gute alte Tradition dass der
Kanzler kurz vor seinem Sommerurlaub vor
der Hauptstadtpresse noch mal Bilanz
zieht natürlich wurde Olaf Scholz auch
zum Ampel zur Fund der Regierungsarbeit
befragt und dem krassen Gegensatz zum
aktuellen ZDF Politbarometer das haben
wir gleich für sie hatte der Kanzler
überwiegend Lob für die Arbeit seines
Kabinetts dazu und zum Thema afd-umfrage
hoch Daniel pontzen
pünktlich zum Ferienbeginn in Berlin gab
der Kanzler seiner Regierung zunächst
selbst ein Zeugnis mehr als 10 Minuten
lang referierte er im Notendurchschnitt
kleines nach ziemlich glatter 1 dennoch
blieben Fragen etwa zum Erstarken der
AFD meine These ist es nicht daran dass
sich eben doch nicht so viele
Bürgerinnen und Bürger so sicher sind
wie die Zukunft sein wird gar nicht
jetzt sondern 10 20 und 30 Jahren
zentral sei daher Respekt und nun die
richtigen Weichen zu stellen das tue die
Ampel ich bin ganz zuversichtlich dass
AFD bei der nächsten Bundestagswahl
nicht viel anders abschneiden wird als
bei der letzten dafür müsste man etwa
auch bei der Klimapolitik jeweils die
Mehrheit der Bevölkerung für all seine
Maßnahmen hinter sich bringen Politik
können nicht nur delegiert werden auf
irgendeine Instanz die das entscheidet
und dann
ja rücksichtslos durchzieht die
funktioniert nicht das ist ein Fehler
das will ich ganz ausdrücklich sagen das
ist etwas was ich für eine falsche
Politik halte beim Thema Migration
äußerte sich Scholz angesichtskonstant
hoher zuzugszahlen auch zur Forderung
nach stärkeren Grenzkontrollen wir haben
mit unseren Nachbarländern also mit der
Schweiz mit der Tschechien und mit Polen
konkrete Vereinbarung wie wir
kooperieren damit das im Blick damit das
gelingt und dann müssen wir gucken das
reicht oder nicht auch wurde Scholz zu
den jüngsten Ausschreitungen in
Freibädern gefragt etwa ob die auch
Folge von
integrationsdefiziten sein
wer sowas macht ist
verhält sich nicht so wie unsere Regeln
sind es ist völlig richtig wenn daraus
die Konsequenz gezogen wird jetzt auch
Polizei einzusetzen wir müssen ja immer
hingehen und dafür sorgen dass ganz
schnell klar wird dass wir als Staat das
nicht dulden er selbst sei seit 40
Jahren nicht im Freibad geschwommen
verriet der schmunzelnd Heiterkeit auch
nach dem handygeräusche störten also wer
rein Klingelton auf Jingle Bell
eingestellt hat der ist es
zum dann wieder ernsten Abschluss einer
Appell künftig solle seine Regierung
ihre Ergebnisse weniger laut produzieren
die sollen dann auch schneller kommen
ich glaube das wird uns auch gelingen
nun aber geht auch der Kanzler erst mal
den Urlaub auf den er sich auch durchaus
freue
genau hingehört in Berlin hat heute auch
Theo Koll Theo der Kanzler überwiegend
heiter gelassen und zufrieden aber es
kam mir heute auch auf die Zwischentöne
an
ja diese selbst zufriedene Gelassenheit
die gehört ja bei Olaf Scholz einerseits
zum Naturell sie ist aber auch Teil
seiner politischen Strategie um damit
gegen die weitgehende Verunsicherung und
die Zukunftsängste der Menschen
anzugehen und ja die Zwischentöne waren
heute das interessanteste natürlich hat
der Kanzler die Arbeit der
Ampelkoalition vor allem gelobt auch
wenn er sich das Ganze manchmal weniger
laut gewünscht hätte das fällt aber eher
in dem Bereich der erwartbaren
Selbstkritik dann aber sagt ja noch
etwas anderes politische Entscheidungen
bräuchten so Scholz eine breite
Unterstützung in der Bevölkerung des
miteinander funktionieren besser wenn
man nicht dem anderen mitteilt das ist
genau die Fassung nachdem man zu leben
hat Zitat Ende das Wort grüne fiel in
dem Zusammenhang nicht aber das ist ja
genau das Wesen von Zwischentönen und
dann ergänzte Scholz noch mit Blick auf
die Klimapolitik jeder einzelne Regelung
müsste so sein dass sie in einer
Volksabstimmung eine Mehrheit findet und
da hätte sich die Ursprungsfassung als
heizungsgesetzes wahrscheinlich ziemlich
schwer getan danke für die Einschätzung
nach Berlin Theo Koll also alles in
allem große selbst Zufriedenheit beim
Kanzler im aktuellen ZDF Politbarometer
da sieht das ganz anders aus guten Abend
schon Matthias vornhoff Matthias was
sagen denn die Befragten wie zufrieden
sind Sie mit der Bundesregierung na die
Koalition ist im Dauerstreit so nehmen
es jedenfalls viele war entsprechend
kritisch wird sie beurteilt die
Bundesregierung macht ihre Sache eher
gut das Sagen 40 Prozent eine Mehrheit
von 54 Prozent aber findet sie macht
ihre Arbeit schlecht trotzdem erwarten
69 Prozent dass die Ampel bis zur
Bundestagswahl in gut zwei Jahren hält
wie wirkt sich all das aus wenn am
nächsten Sonntag Bundestagswahl wäre
können wir die SPD auf 17 Prozent minus
1 die Union auf 27 Prozent minus 1 grüne
16 unverändert FDP 7+1 die AFD erneut
mit einem Rekordwert 20 Prozent plus 1
Die Linke vier Prozent minus 1 also im
nächsten Jahr Matthias da finden wir im
Osten diverse Landtagswahlen statt da
ist die AFD sehr stark und in Reaktion
darauf wünschen sich viele neue
zusammenarbeiten was ist da rausgekommen
eine klare Mehrheit aller Befragten ist
für Koalitionsgespräche der CDU mit der
Linken im Osten 60 Prozent finden das
richtig
34% nicht auch für viele Unionsanhänger
ist das kein Tabu mehr 50% sind dafür
47% dagegen
der Sommer ist heiß und viel zu trocken
ist das eine Folge des Klimawandels
ja das ist deine Folge des Klimawandels
sagen 67 Prozent
30% halten die Hitze und Dürre in diesem
Sommer für normale Wetterschwankungen
so viel zum aktuellen Politbarometer
vielen Dank Matthias das war ja nur ein
erster Aufschlag das ausführliche
Politbarometer das können Sie wie immer
im heute journal sehen heute ab 22 Uhr
oder Sie klicken sich in aller Ruhe
selbst durch die neuesten Zahlen
jederzeit in unserer ZDF heute App etwa
zu den Beliebtheitswerten der Politiker
oder auch sehr interessant die Stimmung
in der Bevölkerung zu den großen
politischen Fragen über Jahre hinweg
betrachtet
vor zwei Jahren um diese Zeit da warnte
sich in Teilen von Rheinland-Pfalz und
Nordrhein-Westfalen eine Katastrophe an
extreme Regenfälle ließen die AH die
Erft und viele Nebenflüsse blitzartig
anschwellen das ganze Ausmaß sichtbar
wie hier in Altena am nächsten Morgen
ein 185 Menschen verloren insgesamt in
dieser Nacht ihr Leben viele mehr ihr zu
Hause in Nordrhein-Westfalen riss die
erdmaßen mit die Altstadt von Bad
Münstereifel fast komplett zerstört
besonders schwer traf es viele Orte im
Aatal wie Schuld über das Gedenken heute
berichtet jetzt an seinem Stern
es ist die Erinnerung an die Toten der
Flut an das Leid der Angehörigen die
Verzweiflung der Familien und an die
gewaltigen Zerstörungen heute vor zwei
Jahren wurde das Aartal schwer verwundet
wurden Menschen in den Tod gerissen
wir sind alles traumatisiert und es
dauert das wird man auch nicht los ne
und mir tun die Menschen auch leid weil
mein Kind viele die
ertrunken sind die Geräusche im Ohr
durch die Flut bis heute geblieben die
Wunden der Katastrophe auch zwei Jahre
danach sichtbar und spürbar der
Wiederaufbau für viele ein quälend
langer Kampf gegen Bürokratie oder
handwerkermangel die Fehler vor der Flut
längst nicht aufgearbeitet ein echtes
Hochwasserschutzkonzept etwa soll es
erst Ende 2024 geben sagt die
Landesregierung
planen wieder aufbauen und Neues
schaffen kostet eben Kraft und braucht
auch Zeit und ich verstehe dass manches
für die Menschen zu lange dauert oder zu
kompliziert ist ihnen sage ich zu dass
wir als Landesregierung immer weiter
daran arbeiten konkrete Lösungen zu
finden
am 14 Juli 2021 kommen die bis dahin
unvorstellbar großen Wassermassen sie
reißen Brücken straßenhäuser Existenzen
mit sich die Fluten wüten mit enormer
Kraft Menschen ertrinken das jüngste
Todesopfer war vier Jahre alt
schätzungen zufolge gibt es im Alter
mehr als 9000 zerstörte Gebäude mehr als
40.000 Betroffene
Normalität
die einen lieben Menschen verloren haben
sagt der Bürgermeister von Bad
Neuenahr-Ahrweiler und fügt hinzu die
Folgen der Jahrhundertflut bleiben in
den Köpfen in den Seelen auch zwei Jahre
danach
wir sprechen mit Christel Haas bei der
Gedenkfeier in Bad Neuenahr-Ahrweiler
die gerade zu Ende gegangen ist Christel
zwei Jahre nach der Flutkatastrophe
kämpfen viele betroffen ja immer noch
wie sehen die Herausforderungen aus
na die größte Herausforderung ist
eigentlich jetzt zwei Jahre nach der
Flut die durchzuhalten nicht aufzugeben
und zu akzeptieren dass der Wiederaufbau
eben nicht morgen oder nächstes Jahr
schon zu Ende ist sondern dass er sehr
sehr lange dauern wird denn wenn man
durch das Aartal fährt dann ist es so
dass es ein Teil der Gegensätze ist auf
der einen Seite ist schon sehr viel auch
gemessen an dem enormen Schaden der
entstanden ist durch die Flut sehr viel
wieder aufgebaut aber direkt daneben
sieht man dann Ruinen sieht man dann die
große Zerstörung und da passiert nichts
und das ist für die die betroffen sind
und bei denen eben nichts vorangeht sehr
zermürmt extrem belastend und das geht
eben auch an die Substanz weil man muss
komplizierte Anträge stellen man muss
warten es braucht Gutachter die nicht
kommen die keine Zeit haben Handwerker
die es nicht gibt weil die auch
ausgebucht sind das ist einfach etwas
was den Leuten wirklich Schmerzen
bereitet und daran das gilt es jetzt zu
verändern das geht aber nur langsam
Marlo 3 hat versprochen dass keiner hier
im Alter alleine gelassen wird aber man
muss dazu auch sagen das wird lange
dauern da muss man dicke Bretter bohren
und es braucht einen langen Atem und Mut
in die Zukunft zu schauen vielen Dank
nach Bad Neuenahr
jetzt zu dem was in Deutschland sehr
emotional sehr kontrovers diskutiert
wird den Protestaktionen der sogenannten
letzten Generation sie haben auch heute
wieder in diversen Städten versucht den
Verkehr lahm zu legen dabei gab es auch
verletzte viele Politiker verurteilen
die bundesweiten Proteste scharf schon
gestern hatten Aktion in den Flugverkehr
in Hamburg und Düsseldorf gestört mehr
jetzt von Stefan Kelch
ja in Bremen lassen die Demonstranten
keinen Zweifel was das soll und wen sie
adressieren mit den heutigen Blockaden
die Bundesregierung die ihre Ansicht
nach das Klimaschutzgesetz breche das
Land in den Kollaps führen würde immer
mehr Menschen
verstehen grüne Politiker urteilen die
letzte Generation schade der Sache des
Klimaschutzes ich halte diese Aktion für
ausdrücklich falsch sie schadet dem
Anliegen sie schadet dem Klimaschutz
es ist ein lupenreines Eigentor
der Bundesverkehrsminister meint die
Aktivisten überschritten Grenzen das was
die letzte Generation hier betreibt ist
vollkommen inakzeptabel und muss mit
allen Härten des rechtsstaatsverfolgt
werden in 26 Städten legen Aktivisten
der letzten Generation heute zeitweise
den Verkehr komplett lahm selbst für
wohl meine Passanten scheint diese Form
des Protestes schwer nachvollziehbar sie
erreichen ja niemanden damit gäbe es
eine Alternative wo sie die Menschen
wirklich erreichen mit dem was sie so
furchtbar auch aufbringen man kann die
Protestformen der letzten Generation
weitestgehend in das Spektrum das
zivilen Ungehorsams einsortieren das
heißt sie sind radikaler konfrontativer
als das for future der Fall ist er ist
aber selten im Moment des Ungehorsams
auch beliebt
das wird durch die Aktionen heute nicht
besser bei Nürnberg am Ende eines Staus
auf einer blockierten Autobahn ein
schwerer Unfall anderen Arzt wird eine
Aktivistin verletzt durch eine
verärgerte Autofahrerin
Spanien Frankreich vor allem aber
Griechenland und Italien Südeuropa steht
ein extrem heißes Wochenende bevor bis
zu 48 Grad werden etwa auf Sizilien
erwartet es könnten die höchsten
Temperaturen werden die in Europa jemals
gemessen wurden besonders problematisch
ist die Hitze in den Städten so hat
Athen schon Maßnahmen rund um die
Akropolis getroffen das Rote Kreuz
verteilt Wasserflaschen und gibt Tipps
wie man mit dem Wetter am besten klar
kommt um die Mittagszeit wurde das
Wahrzeichen der Stadt zeitweise sogar
geschlossen Helfer berichten das gestern
rund 40 Touristen wegen Schwächeanfällen
behandelt werden mussten
heute ist 14 Juli das ist na klar auch
der französische Nationalfeiertag nach
den schweren Unruhen in letzter Zeit
feiert das Land mit starken
Sicherheitsvorkehrung bisher bleibt
alles ruhig einen besonderen Akzent
setzt die französische Regierung bei der
großen traditionellen Militärparade als
Ehrengast wurde Indien begrüßt Anna
Arendt aus Paris
Flugschau über dem Himmel von Paris
Frankreich feiert die Republik und
mittendrin ein Präsident der eine
Rückkehr Zuordnung demonstrieren will
nach mehreren krisenrentenprotesten und
zuletzt den jugendkrawallen in vielen
Vorstädten
ich habe nach den Bildern überlegt die
Reise nach Paris abzusagen aber es ist
ruhig geblieben auch für die Touristen
es ist ein Festtag mit dem wir die
Freiheit feiern wir alle in Frankreich
zusammen
tatsächlich genießen Sie vielerort wie
auch hier in einer Pariser Vorstadt den
freien Tag starten mit kleinen festen in
die Sommerferien
es ist natürlich nicht so groß wie in
Paris wir haben hier ja auch weniger
Geld aber jede Gemeinde organisiert
etwas überall wird der Tag zelebriert
wir stehen zusammen wir feiern den 14
Juli die Unruhen treiben uns nicht
auseinander
und auch das ist der 14 Juli eine
militärshow gerichtet ein Partner aus
dem Ausland der indische premier ist
Ehrengast in diesem Jahr wird trotz der
bedenklichen Menschenrechtslage in
seiner Heimat umworben aus
geostrategischem Interesse
wir werden unsere Partnerschaft heute
noch weiter vertiefen um uns der
internationalen Krise und dem globalen
Herausforderungen entgegenzustellen
zu den Herausforderungen im Inland indes
schweigt der Präsident dabei hatten
viele auf eine persönliche Rede gehofft
an diesem Feiertag der französischen
Nation
Indien nicht nur in Frankreich sondern
auch weiter oben indien will mit einer
Sonde auf dem mondlandten als viertes
Land der Erde nach der Sowjetunion den
USA und China dafür haben sie heute eine
weitere Mission auf den Weg gebracht an
der Ostküste des Landes startete eine
Rakete mit einer unbemannten Mondsonde
ziel ist es Ende August sicher auf der
wenig erforschten Südseite des Mondes zu
landen 2019 waren erster Versuch Indiens
beim Landeanflug gescheitert
jetzt in die USA genauer nach Hollywood
denn die us-filmfabrik steht still nach
den Drehbuchautoren streiken jetzt auch
die filmschauspielerinnen und
Schauspieler ihre Forderung bessere
Gehälter wegen der Inflation und
Regelungen zur künstlichen Intelligenz
die zum Beispiel beim Synchronisieren
von Filmen eingesetzt werden könnte
viele Filmprojekte müssen jetzt wohl
gestoppt werden Benjamin Daniel
berichtet
es sind die weltbekannten wie Matt Damon
die dem Streik ein Gesicht geben doch
hinter dem Protest stehen noch viel mehr
Künstler neben den Drehbuchautoren nun
auch 10000 Schauspieler die Gewerkschaft
die sie repräsentiert konnte mit dem
Verband der Film und TV-Produzenten
trotz langem Ringen keine Einigung
erzielen
die Produzenten tun so als stünden sie
kurz vorm Bankrott entlohnen ihre sie
aus aber gleichzeitig mit hunderten
Millionen Dollars es ist widerlich
neben der Forderung nach höheren Gagen
in inflationszeiten und faireren
gehaltsmodellen geht es ihnen auch um
Zusicherungen in Sachen künstlicher
Intelligenz viele befürchten dass ihr
zunehmender Einsatz Arbeit wegnimmt beim
Schreiben Schauspielern oder synchron
sprechen die Firma Dieb Voodoo zum
Beispiel hat sich auf
gesichtsanpassungen per ki-spezialisiert
eine
nbc-reporterin zeigt wie es funktioniert
30 Minuten lang wird ihre Mimik gescannt
dann wird eine Algorithmus mit den Daten
gefüttert schließlich braucht man nur
noch ein Double und die Software erzeugt
live ein perfektes Abbild der echten
Person
die Bedrohung wird als groß empfunden
das zeigt auch dass die Schauspieler des
neuen Oppenheimer Films ihre Teilnahme
an der Premiere in London abbrachen
sobald der Streik verkündet war
es ist eine existenzielle Bedrohung
unserer Industrie die man ernst nehmen
muss es ist ein schmerzvoller Prozess
aber es geht nicht anders
in einem Interview zeigt der Chef von
Walt Disney wenig Verständnis
ihre Erwartungen sind nicht realistisch
sie machen es schwerer für eine
Industrie die ohnehin schon vor großen
Herausforderungen steht das finde ich
ehrlich gesagt verstörend
der größte Arbeitskampf in Hollywood
seit Jahrzehnten führt dazu das
zahlreiche Dreharbeiten ab sofort
gestoppt sind der Vorhang ist also
erstmal gefallen und niemand weiß so
recht wann er wieder wie gewohnt
aufgehen könnte
ja noch sind wir echt und die Akteure
beim Sport auch um die es jetzt gehen
zuerst Tennis da geht es jetzt um ein
Duell der Generation Christian 15 Jahre
Altersunterschied das ist schon was 36
und kein bisschen müde Novak Djokovic
hat seine neunte final Teilnahme in
Wimpern erkämpft in drei Sätzen gegen
den Italiener Janik Sinner ein durchaus
spannendes Match aber in den
entscheidenden Momenten war derselbe
einfach besser
selbst mit 36 Jahren noch topfit und
gierig auf jeden Ball Nowak chokovic
Jannik Sinner kann noch so erbitterten
Widerstand leisten irgendwann ist klar
sein Gegenüber schlägt sich allenfalls
mal selbst in Wimbledon so zwischendurch
aber nicht wenn es darauf ankommt selbst
wenn Sina Breakball hatte und den
Ballwechsel dominiert jokovic
der Italiener verschlägt
was natürlich nicht heißt dass er nicht
auch selbst punkten kann genial sogar
und so gewinnt Djokovic am Ende mit
sechs drei sechs vier und sieben zu
sechs je älter er wird desto mehr Spaß
scheint ihm zu machen gegen die viel
jüngeren ich glaube 36 ist das neue 26
fühlt sich gut an nur wohl eher nicht
für seine Gegner
ja und am Sonntag dann das Finale der
polymeralk wird die 13 etappe der Tour
de France mit Berg Ankunft auf dem Grand
Colombier gewonnen in der Gesamtwertung
führt noch Jonas weniger nur 9 Sekunden
vor 3da
Überraschung durch Nele Moos bei den
para Leichtathletik Weltmeisterschaften
in Paris sie freut sich in der Klasse
der teilweise gelähmten über Bronze im
waldschwung
damit hat sie nicht gerechnet brauchst
du für Nele Moos
hintertitelverteidigerin Luca aus Ungarn
und der Britin Olivia green zur
Siegesweite von 57 fehlt einiges aber
vier Meter 65 im vierten Versuch
bedeuten persönliche westweite
das wollte ich eigentlich gerne zeigen
aber das ist jetzt noch Bronze ist sie
weit egal die mit 16 Jahren jüngste im
deutschen Team Friederike Brose aus
Brandenburg wird vierte mit vier Metern
die deutschen Fußballerinnen haben den
Jetlag mit acht Stunden Zeitverschiebung
in Australien gut weggesteckt bestens
gelaunt absolvierte das Team von Martina
Forst Tecklenburg nahe der Unterkunft in
wayong das Training noch zehn Tage
bleiben bis zum ersten WM-Spiel gegen
Marokko in Melbourne 10 Tage heißt
Montag 24 Juli ja wenn du Zeit hast
danke Christine wir kommen jetzt zu
einem Künstler der mit seinen
riesengroßen Werken die Schweizer
Berglandschaft verzaubert die Rede ist
von safe sein jüngstes Werk ein Mädchen
und ein Junge die auf skizzenblöcken
ihre Sicht auf die Welt nachzeichnen
benutzt hatte ausschließlich Kreide und
Holzkohle also biologisch abbaubar wie
lange die Werke zu sehen sein werden
hängt dann davon ab wann an den Berg
Hängen des Dorfes wie Lars der Regen
kommt und dann alles wieder weg wäscht
eigentlich viel zu schade sollte da
bleiben finde ich super aus
so morgen erst heißt dann von Westen
gewittrich mehr Wetter gleich von Katja
horneffer das heute journal startet um
22 Uhr mit Maria das lomka morgen
moderiert hier Barbara Hellweg das war's
heute von uns schönen Start ins
Wochenende und auf bald
[Musik]
guten Abend das Tief über den britischen
Inseln bringt uns morgen erstmal schwule
Hits von Südwesten und dann auch
Gewitter das geht in den Mittagsstunden
los und am Nachmittag und Abend auch im
Südwesten danach wird es von Westen
wieder kühler heute Nacht gibt es einige
Regenschauer an der Nordseeküste sonst
ist es häufig klar bei Südostwind die
Temperaturen sinken meist auf 17 bis 13
Grad wärmer bleibt es im Norden und im
Westen bei 20 bis 17 Grad und morgen
gibt es schweißtreibende Temperaturen
von 31 bis 37 Grad von der Ostsee bis
zum Bodensee Kühler ist es in der Eifel
und auch im Westerwald mit 24 25 Grad
denn dort kommen die dichteren Wolken
schon am Vormittag an die bringen Regen
mit und das kann auch schon mal ein
kräftigeres Gewitter dabei sein im Osten
ist das dagegen sonnig nachmittags weil
sie Schauer und Gewitter weiter nach
Norden aus und zum späten Nachmittag und
Abend kann es dann Gewitter von
Frankreich hergeben am Sonntag verlassen
uns diese Regenschauer und Gewitter
ostwärts dann gibt's einen freundlichen
Streifen von Brandenburg bis zur Mosel
einige Schauer und Gewitter bei starkem
Wind aus den westlichen Richtungen
erwarten werden der Nordsee guten Abend